نبدا من ابرز الصواريخ التي اطلقت من قطاع
غزه اذا اليوم البارز جدا هو اطلاق دفعه
كبيره من الصواريخ من داخل قطاع غزه
وتوجهت هذه الصواريخ اكثر من 50 صاروخ
بحسب ما اعلن الى ثلاث تجمعات استيطان في
غلاف غزه اشكون هو تجمع استيطاني كذلك
شاعر هنيغف وايضا اشكول التجمع الاستيطاني
هو الذي يضم اكثر من مستوطنه تتوزع بعدد
سكان بالالاف ما بين
13000 الى
و9000 ويتراوح اعداد المستوطنات بين
2 واعداد اخرى في شاعر هنقف وفي اشكول
البارز ان هذه الصواريخ اطلقت من شمال
قطاع غزه شمال قطاع غزه امس قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه انهى العمليات وانه قضى
على القدرات العسكريه لكتائب القسام
بالتحديد اليوم اضطر الجيش الاسرائيلي كما
يبدو الى اعاده التوغل والعوده الى داخل
الشمال الى شمال قطاع غزه حيث تدور
اشتباكات لا سما في شرق مدينه غزه
واشتباكات عنيفه كانت المنطقه تعرضت لما
نسميه احزمه ناريه وهي الاستهدافات
المتتاليه في نقط طه جغرافيه محدوده
وقريبه جدا
طول الحدود الشماليه وايضا الحدود الشرقيه
تتعرض باستمرار لغارات وقصف عنيف بعد ان
كانت القوات الاسرائيليه قد تمركزت الى
لبضعه ايام عند تخوم هذه المنطقه قرب يعني
بين جحر الديك في منطقه غازه وادي غزه بين
جحر الديك وبين مدينه غزه في الاثناء لم
تهدا امور في وسط قطاع غزه لازلنا نتحدث
عن قوس
اشتباكات ما زال ثابتا الى حد بعيد سيرات
البريج المغازي هناك اشتباكات قويه جدا
وهناك ايضا محاولات مزيد من المحاولات
للتقدم الى دير البلح وهناك خسائر في
الجيش الاسرائيلي بحسب ما تعلن كتائب
القسام وباقي فصائل المقاومه يوم امس كانت
قد اعلنت اس انها
سحبت احدى الفرق الكبرى وعدد من الالويه
ابرزها لواء جولاني من منطقه القتال
لاراحت واستبدلتهم بالويه ووحده اخرى ولكن
هذا لم لا يعني ان الهدوء قد عاد الى خان
يونس والى جنوب القطاع ولا يعني ان الامر
قد استتب ايضا بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال ما
زالت منطقه خان يونس عند اكثر من محور
تشهد اشتباكات عند الجنوب والجنوب الشرقي
بشكل خاص والاشتباكات توصف بانها عنيفه
ومره اخرى نرى استهدافات وغارات اسرائيليه
على اكثر من منطقه ومحور وهذا يبدو انه
تكتيك تستخدمه القوات الاسرائيليه عندما
تفشل بالتقدم نقطه اخيره نشير الى ما يجري
على المستوى السياسي وعلى المستوى السياسي
العسكري وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قال اليوم
ان غياب استراتيجيه الواضحه لمرحله ما بعد
الحرب بمعنى من سيدير قطاع غزه
بدات تعود بتداعيات سلبيه على الجيش وامس
كان قد سرب عن هيرسي هاليفي السي وهو رئيس
الاركان بان غياب استراتيجيه السياسيه
ينعكس على العمليات ويقلص من انجازات
الجيش الاسرائيلي بحسب هاليفي هذ